so I happened to stumble across this
obscure little news report about
something called the molar
maybe Muller investigation probably
haven't heard of it but it is wild stuff
and we'll talk about that but but first
I want to mention stamps.com
listen no one really no one really has
the time to be you know going to the
post office you only get 75 to 80 years
of life at most for for most of us
someone some of us not even that much
you don't want to spend your precious
allotment of days sitting in traffic
dealing with parking lugging all your
your mail and packages around it's a
huge hassle so that's why you need
stamps.com
it's one of the most popular time-saving
tools for small businesses stamps.com
eliminates trips to the post office and
it saves you money with discounts that
you can't even get at the post office so
stamps comm brings all the amazing
services of the US Postal Service right
to your computer so whether you're small
small office sending invoices you're an
online seller shipping you know products
and different items out or if you're a
warehouse is sending thousands of
packages a day stamps comm handles it
all with ease simply use your computer
to print official US postage 24/7 for
any letter any package any class of mail
anywhere that you want to send your
stuff to once your mail is ready you
just hand it to your mail carrier you
drop it in a mail box whatever you want
to do it's that simple with Stan's comm
you get five cents of every first-class
stamp and up to 40% off Priority Mail
not to mention it's a fraction of the
cost of those expensive you know postage
meters that you can get so stamps comm
is a no-brainer saving your time it
saves you money and that's why you've
got over 700,000 businesses that use
stamps comm so right now my listeners
get a special offer that includes a four
week trial plus free postage and a
digital scale without any long-term
commitment you really can't lose their
go to stamps calm click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in Walsh that stamps comm enter
Walsh and you get all those great deals
go do that right now
all right molar as you no doubt heard
the Muller report has come back negative
Trump did not test positive for
collusion he is not a secret Russian
agent it turns out he didn't obstruct
justice there's no evidence of that
there are going to be no indictments
that means that it's it's over the whole
thing is over
of course this news is not really news
to any rational person the idea that
Trump was some sort of Putin henchman
was always ridiculous but this is the
angle that the Democrats decided to
pursue for for the past two years and by
the way the idea that Trump was working
for Putin it's ridiculous for many
reasons not the least of which being you
know the fact that the Trump was out
there on the campaign trail saying nice
things about Putin that'll in that
that's that's one of the reasons why
Democrats got it into their head the
Left got it into their head that oh he
must be working with Putin well if he
was then he wouldn't be out saying those
things in the first place so that's
that's your first hint right but I think
we should really stop here and meditate
on the profound stupidity of these
people I'm talking about the left
Democrats the media they're all one and
the same right of all the things that
they could focus on of all the things
that they could criticize Trump for that
they of all the all the the points that
they could criticize about Trump and his
administration everything they decide to
spend two years on this conspiracy
theory and it's a conspiracy theory that
now must officially be consigned to a
category that's occupied by the
moon-landing hoax and 9/11 truther ISM
and Sandy Hook truther ISM and the Flat
Earth theory and so on
utterly stupid incredible irrational
conspiracy theories that that's that
what this is now that's what this always
was and birtherism too you remember the
idea that Obama was you know couldn't be
President because he wasn't born here
it's this this is in that same category
and in fact I think you would say in
many ways that Russian collusion is
basically the less birtherism although
as someone pointed out to me on Twitter
actually the the birtherism was already
the left's birtherism because that was a
a line of attack that originated with
the Clinton campaign but in any case
this is this is what the Democrats chose
to go with with regards to Trump there
are other things they could have focused
on President Trump
we must admit does in fact provide his
enemies with plenty of opportunities to
criticize many fruitful points of
criticism that they could explore but
they said no thanks we're not interested
in that we're gonna go with Trump as a
secret Russian agent instead that's
gonna be our strategy just astonishingly
astonishingly stupid and this seems to
be Trump's greatest skill or I don't
even know if you could call it a skill
because I'm not sure that he doesn't on
purpose but it's certainly his best
defense mechanism whether intentional or
not that somehow for some reason he
provokes his opponents into criticizing
him for the dumbest and most irrelevant
things leaving potentially legitimate
avenues of criticism unexplored and they
always go for this thing over here the
the fantastic the incredible the
irrational that's what they go for and
it's quite a spectacle to behold but I
want you to think about something else
the left has been very
this weekend as you can imagine as I'm
sure you've noticed about the news that
there was no collusion right Rachel
Maddow I'm not gonna bother playing the
clip but this has been going around
online Maddow on her show was was
basically on the verge of tears over it
they're they're all they're distraught
very upset depressed angry but think
about what it is exactly that's
upsetting them they're upset that the
president didn't collude with Russia
that's what they're upset about think
about that Muller came back and said
yeah there's no evidence president
didn't do it right well we should all be
happy about that IIIi don't think I
should even have to clarify this but
when you find out if there was ever any
doubt in your head in the first place
when you find out that the President did
not collude with a foreign government to
undermine our election process when you
find that out if you are a you know if
you are a person who loves America if
you're a reasonable person a reasonable
patriotic person when you find that out
your reaction is going to be oh well
that's good great news everybody should
be happy about that that is good that is
objectively good news for everyone but
the Democrats aren't happy and so if
you're if there was if you're wondering
whether these people really care about
the integrity of our democratic process
whether they care about you know truth
if you were ever wondering about that
well this should clarify it for you that
no they don't care about that stuff
because they wanted they wanted the
president to have been guilty of this
they were hoping that it did happen you
may remember back when Obama was elected
and there
huge outcry on the left because rush
limbaugh said that i forget what his
exact words were but he said something
like I hope the president fails that was
the those were that was the phrase that
he used taken out of context and so
Democrats latched on to that and they
said oh how terrible how could you be
rooting against the president well in
the context it was clear that Limbaugh
was saying I I hope he fails in his
agenda because I opposed his agenda I
think it's a bad agenda for America I
hope he that he fails in carrying it out
which is a perfectly fine thing to say
and that's what you would expect the
opponents of a president's agenda to say
but here now we have but the way that
they they miss construed it is they said
oh no you well you're just rooting
against you're rooting against America
you want bad things to happen to America
you want his whole presidency to be a
disaster that's what you want and that's
not what he said but that really is what
the left apparently wants they are again
I would emphasize for the fifth time
they are upset that the President of the
United States did not collude with
Russia and undermine our democratic
process they're upset which means that
they wish he did all right here's a clip
that I do want to play for you Glenn
Greenwald shared this on Twitter I'm not
I'm not sure if he's the one who
compiled the clips or not but this is
this kind of condenses to years of media
hysteria T hysteria into two minutes so
I want you to watch this breaking news a
bombshell
today is a turning point today was
historically bad for President Trump
today was a turning point a turning
point we're at a turning point here the
beginning of the end for the Trump
presence we have another bombshell Mike
Pence might have to assume the office of
the presidency rumblings of the word
impeachment breaking news another
bombshell out of the White House I
believe this is the beginning of the end
I did chef it's really the beginning of
being maybe feeling the walls closing in
on him all the walls closing in on him
the walls closing in on him breaking
news a new bomb
so one astrologer says this means the
beginning of the end for President
Donald Trump Trump will resign is this
the tipping point I know we've said it
over and over you think this is a
tipping point and over and over this is
a tipping point and over and over
breaking news president Trump off the
rails it was the beginning of the end
today the beginning of the end
breaking news tonight new bombs show
this is the beginning at the end the
beginning of the end the walls are
closing in the walls closing in breaking
overnight bombshells there's a very
dramatic day and I think it might be
near a tipping point you think this is a
tipping point
December 1st 2017 you can mark it down
this is the day that everything changed
the beginning of the end beginning of
the end the beginning of the end the
beginning of the end at the beginning of
the begin tonight with the bombshell
Donald Trump isn't a lot of trouble
Trump is in trouble the president will
resign another hour another bombshell
this is a tipping point
flops going down this president could be
impeached resignation resignation I
don't think this president is going to
serve out his term mr. Trump will not
serve out his term he will not serve out
his term no way no how breaking news and
absolute bonds Donald Trump is not he's
done it's over it's over
walls closing in walls closing in this
is going to be the Achilles heel
breaking news tonight I expect Trump to
depart this week will be the watershed
week Trump is in big trouble
Trump's a lot trouble it's a sign of a
terrified old man who feels the walls
closing in the walls are increasingly
closing in on him tonight the walls are
closing in today changed everything this
is the beginning of the end today the
biggest tipping point for the Trump
administration what a historic day the
bomb shows he's underwater he feels the
walls closing in turning-point we may be
at a tipping fork it's the beginning of
the end at the beginning of the end
another bombshell bombshell a bombshell
bombshell bombshell this is a bombshell
how completely embarrassing is that for
the news media if they're capable of
being embarrassed which I don't think
they are we have to understand if we
don't already that they're what you just
saw there okay that's not news and
that's not a news media there is no news
media we don't have a news media
that is a category that doesn't exist in
America it simply doesn't exist anymore
if it ever did what you saw there is not
news those are not journalists that is
propaganda this is the same media that
while it was pushing the Russian
collusion conspiracy theory for four
year for two years while it was doing
that at the same time it gave us the
Covington Catholic thing it gave us the
Smollett hoax it gave us Cavanaugh and
so on and so on
these are ideological agents these are
propaganda merchants they are narrative
crafters that's what they're in the
business of doing they're not in the
business of telling the truth and I know
that everyone says this right we all
we're always putting this out fake news
and everything well we all say it but I
don't know if we've if we really let it
sink in that we do not have a news media
that you simply cannot trust what you
hear from them because they're not
interested in in getting to the truth
now we should ask ourselves why is it
that the media fell for this Russian
collusion hoax for two years I don't
think it's it's it's not the case that
in many cases I don't think it's the
case that they were you know inventing
this out of whole cloth and all of the
anonymous sources that they were hearing
and everything I don't think they
invented that they didn't make that up
but the point is they so badly wanted it
to be true
they were so propelled by their biases
they so badly want it to be true that
they didn't apply their their brains to
this and they didn't vet any of it and
so any anonymous source that they heard
that said oh molars about to come out
with indictments and Trump's going to be
in a jail cell tomorrow
well there was no skepticism there was
nothing like that there was no vetting
because they wanted it to be true and
that's what motivates these people and
that's why we simply cannot trust them
it was the same thing with Kavanagh as I
said Smollett Covington Catholic all of
those you know we call those media
hoaxes and in a sense they are media
hoaxes but we have to understand how the
media hoax works ok the media didn't
invent those things the media didn't
make up the incident with Covington
Catholic the media CNN didn't invent the
idea that Cavanaugh was the the leader
of some gang rape crew in high school
and they were going around to parties
and raping women and everything
CNN didn't buy that sweat Nick Julia
sweat Nick made that up so the way the
media hoax works is they decide based on
what they want to be true which is based
on their ideology they decide which
rumors they're going to believe without
any discernment as I said without any
vetting without any attempt to actually
get to the bottom of it they'll take the
the rumors and then they amplify them so
that's that's how the fake news works
it's not so much most of the time that
they're sitting around all the different
you know supposed journalists and
anchors are sitting around and
smoke-filled darkened rooms hatching
what fake stories that are going to tell
next that's not the way it works it's
just that they're so driven by ideology
and when it comes to Trump they're so
driven by their their hatred for him
that they will that they will accept
whatever rumor that they hear and
they'll put it on you know they'll put
it in front of the cameras and they'll
disseminate it with Cavanaugh because of
the threat that they believe Cavanaugh
poses to to so-called abortion rights
again it was another thing where they
they hate him so much and they are so
blinded by ideology that even a story
about gang rape Cruz they will take that
and they'll they'll run with it so
no credibility and no reason to listen
to these people and it's been that way
for a long time but hopefully now we've
all finally caught on okay what else
barbra streisand's said I'm not going to
spend much time on this but Barbara
Barbara Streisand's said in an interview
that she believes she believes the
Michael Jackson accusers she believes
that the story that they're telling but
she also said that Jackson was just
fulfilling his quote sexual needs and
the kids he molested were thrilled to be
there quote those are her quotes and she
said that being molested didn't kill
them because they ended up getting
married and they're fine now she
actually said all those things as
verbatim quotes okay there's not much
analysis to offer here it's obviously a
horrific ly disgusting thing to say so I
think we all hopefully understand that
but the only reason I bring it up is
because I suspect that she is not the
only Hollywood celebrity who feels this
way why do you think there are so many
open secrets in Hollywood well why do
you think it is that a guy like Michael
Jackson could get away with doing this
for decades it's because I think quite a
few of the people in Hollywood feel
exactly like Barbra Streisand did and so
the only difference though is most of
them know that when they're in front of
cameras they're not they're supposed to
pretend otherwise they're supposed to
fake outrage and all of that stuff but
Barbra Streisand forgot to do that this
time and she just let her true colors
show and her attitude is you know not a
big deal so let's not let us be
appropriately horrified by what Barbra
Streisand said but let us not think that
she's the only one in that camp who
feels that way
all right Kamala Harris has come out and
said that she wants a federal program -
she wants all kinds of federal programs
because there aren't enough of those
already she but this time she wants a
federal program to boost the salaries of
teachers this is what she says she says
in America public school teachers are
paid about
thirteen thousand a year less than other
college graduates that could be mortgage
payments or the cost of groceries for a
family for a year it's a national
failure it's time we give America's
teachers a raise the LA Times offers a
little bit more it says a study by the
Economic Policy Institute a liberal
think tank found that public school
teachers in 2017 made 11% less than
similar professionals with college
degrees even after taking into account
benefits which are often higher for
teachers than many private sector
workers Harris will commit to quote
closing the teacher pay gap within her
first term as president details of the
initiative including the price tag and
how the program will be structured will
be released in the coming week ok now I
mentioned this on on social media and I
got into trouble because I pointed out
the obvious here and the obvious point
is that yes teachers make apparently 11%
less than other professionals with
college degrees if we're going to take
this liberal think tank at its word
which I don't anyway but fine for the
sake of argument
okay well teachers also get an enormous
amount of vacation time don't they they
don't work the whole summer
they get breaks in the winter they get
breaks in the spring they get every
federal holiday off they get a whole lot
of three-day weekends and that sort of
thing if it snows they don't have to go
to work all that stuff so think about
that imagine whatever you do for a
living if you're not a teacher because
if you're not a teacher you can't even
it's hard to even conceive of this
imagine getting a vacation every winter
every spring and then you get two months
off in the summer also
so yeah they get paid 11% less they also
work 11% less they probably work a much
much more than 11% less people don't
like it when you when you point this out
I had a whole bunch of teachers
attacking me well
I pointed this out saying I don't
understand being a teacher is really
hard they worked 50 to 60 hours a week
during the school year it's very
difficult they got to bring their work
home with them so on and so forth they
have to do the professional development
stuff during the summer they have to go
to you know they have things that
they're supposed to be doing during the
summer so it's not all just lounging in
the shade okay that's fine I understand
that and I understand that many teachers
do work hard so yeah they have to take
their work home with them that the grade
papers and stuff yeah there are a lot of
people to take their work home with them
so teachers are not alone in that there
are many people who work 50 to 60 hours
a week during school year and then they
continue working 50 or 60 hours a week
during the summer and they only get two
weeks of vacation three weeks of
vacation for the entire year there are a
lot of people in that category so the
question is if you've got people who
work those kinds of hours all year long
would it make sense for teachers who
work those kinds of hours only for nine
months of the year to make as much as
the ones who are working like that 12
months a year I don't think so uh after
the fact remains after taking into
account whatever you have to do in the
summer professional development whatever
taking classes whatever else teachers
still get close to two months off in the
summer plus their winter and spring
breaks federal holidays like I said all
that
now you can't deny that that's a simple
fact and obviously it seems to me your
pay is going to to reflect that if I
went to my employer the daily wire and I
said listen I'm not gonna give you any
content in June or July so I need those
two months off plus count me out for two
weeks during around Christmas and a week
around around Easter and I went every I
want every federal holiday off and if it
snows I'm not I'm not gonna you're not
getting anything if I went to my job and
said that do you think they're gonna
keep paying me the same amount no of
course not because you get paid to work
that's that's the whole point that's the
whole I
dear but behind hobby having a job is
that you're paid to work and so if
you're only working a total of nine
months a year then yeah your your pay is
going to be indicative of that I'm not
saying teachers don't work hard I'm not
attacking teachers I'm simply pointing
out something that I think is is
relevant and the fact that teachers get
so defensive when you bring this up it's
it is a you know you you protesting too
much kind of situation where they get so
defensive another point about this and
this is why I get uncomfortable anytime
we look at a an entire category or a
whole profession or a gender like what
people say women are underpaid and all
the stuff or when it comes to the
minimum wage we say well we need to make
sure that people who are working at
fast-food restaurants get paid more
anytime we do that with these broads
sweeping kinds of statements about this
whole group of people they're all
underpaid I'm always uncomfortable with
that
because within that group you know there
are going to be some people who are very
hardworking very good at what they do
and and do deserve to get paid more but
there are also gonna be some people who
are terrible at what they do and are in
our basically worthless on the job and
whatever they're getting paid right now
is too much so that's the case for
people making minimum wage at a Burger
King it's the case for you know and it's
the case for teachers so if you're
sitting there saying teachers need to
get paid more what do you mean teachers
need to get paid more every teacher
needs to get paid are you telling me
that I couldn't I
you don't think I could find some
teachers who definitely don't deserve to
get paid more because I'm telling you I
can I had some teachers like that I went
to public school for 13 years I had some
great teachers I also had some teachers
who their method of teaching was to hand
out a you know worksheet and to just sit
at their desk
he's doing whatever they're doing in
other words they didn't teach at all
they never I had tea and we all had
teachers like this I had teachers who
never taught they never did any teaching
they just they said read this part of
the book here's your textbook here's a
worksheet and that's it not gonna be any
lectures I'm not gonna explain anything
if you ask a question I'm going to get
angry that you asked the question and I
won't be able to answer because I don't
know the subject I mean these kinds of
teachers exist right we all know that so
do those teachers deserve to get a raise
too no the problem is precisely because
of the teachers union the problem is
that is that we can't get rid of them so
anytime we get into this discussion we
seem to be ignoring the fact that there
are some really bad teachers out there
and that's another point that you're not
allowed to make because teachers our
teachers are a a group of people that we
have canonized before before death they
have they have gotten a a pre death
canonization or they're all saints and
they're all martyrs and everything and
some of them are pretty close to Saints
it seems like given what they deal with
and and what a heroically good job they
do in the circumstances but not all I
don't know how the percentages break
down you know good good teachers - bad
teachers what's the percentage there's a
lot of in between in the Middle's as
well you know so it's not all black and
white in that sense but we can't deny
that those bad teachers do exist and
certainly do not deserve a raise which
is what they would get if you have some
kind of federal program giving them all
a raise well then you're giving it to
the bad ones as well how about we do
this on a case-by-case basis see if we
were to get rid of the teachers union
and tenure and all of that then maybe
what the school systems could do is when
you have these worthless lump on the log
type teachers who don't do anything and
are terrible at their job terrible their
job because they don't even attempt to
do their job well if you could get rid
of them and free up that that income
then maybe you could start giving raise
to the good ones I to me that seems like
a very very reasonable way of going
about things it's one of the reasons I
don't like the minimum wage I don't
think there should be any minimum wage
when I go to a fast-food restaurant
we've all we've all had this experience
sometimes you go to a fast-food
restaurant
it seems rather often you go to a
fast-food restaurant and the person
behind the counter is awful I mean all
they're doing anyway is just is just
pushing buttons on a cash register and
they can't even do that well they screw
that up and they're very solemn and
they're they're gloomy and there's
basically scowling at you they're mad
that you even came in and are daring to
place a food order at all those kinds of
people should be getting paid nothing I
mean their heart they should be getting
paid five cents they're so bad at their
job but then sometimes you go to a
fast-food restaurant and you there's
someone behind the counter who's just on
the ball and they're energetic and
they're happy and they put a smile on
your face it's difficult to put a smile
on my face so if you can do that that's
impressive and there are those types and
you think well this person should be
getting paid $30 an hour they're so good
at what they're doing I went to a fast
food restaurant a few days ago and the
person behind the counter they were so
good and friendly that they actually
succeeded in getting me to to order more
food than I originally plan to do they
were suggesting other items on the menu
and usually when they do that I say no I
don't want to but this person was so
friendly about it I said you know what
yeah I'll take that too so that's
someone who's worth a lot to the company
and they should be getting paid but the
problem is you can't give them the raise
because you have to you know there's
this minimum out amount you have to pay
to these people over here who are
worthless so that's the problem with
that I think all right let's uh let's
skip over to emails Matt wall show at
gmail.com Matt wall show at gmail.com
actually this first email is is not an
email at all it was a message sent to me
on Twitter and this is from Nikola Tesla
which I presume is a pseudonym but who
knows
it says I'm taking a very unpopular and
seemingly callous position Marc Gomez
was arrested for
alleged unprovoked attack on an elderly
woman on the New York subway yet
according to witnesses she was
brandishing a knife and threatening to
kill his daughter who can see him who
you can see follows him off of the
subway after he kicks the woman multiple
times allegedly she is mentally ill and
this is not the first time she has
threatened people with a knife if we as
conservatives have learned anything from
the Covington Catholic video and this
Mallette case it's to reserve judgment
until the facts are revealed so many
people are jumping to conclusions and
making the assumption that that he
should have walked away or called the
police consider the context you're stuck
on a subway car in Brooklyn at 3:00 a.m.
with the crazy woman threatening to
murder your daughter just before the
doors open you haven't you have a choice
walk away and hope she doesn't follow or
take action to incapacitate the threat
it's not popular but in that situation
the man had every right to make sure his
daughter was not murdered okay this is
actually not the only message I got like
this because I wrote about this case on
Friday and let's let's give this a
little bit of context in case you didn't
you didn't see this video as I said I
wrote about it on Friday it is an attack
against an elderly woman on a train in
New York the attack was caught on video
and I'll show you the video now fair
warning this is quite disturbing but but
here it is
[Music]
okay so that scumbag was caught thank
God but he now claims as the person who
sent the message alludes to or his
lawyer claims that the attack was in
self-defense
the woman an elderly a 78 year old
homeless mentally ill woman was talking
about stabbing people or something okay
even if that's true and when I when I
wrote about this case and I had some
very harsh words for this guy there were
a few people who said to me well we
don't know the context don't jump to
conclusions it's not fair for you to
jump to conclusion and I said at the
time I don't care what the context is
there is no context none that could
possibly make it okay
to kick an old woman in the head while
she's sitting on a bench in a subway
train
there is no context that could ever make
that acceptable and I shouldn't have to
explain this in fact if you're kicking
someone in the head that's a pretty good
indication that what you're doing is not
self-defense
unless you're Bruce Lee because if
you're kicking someone in the head for
most of us that means that the person is
in a position where they probably not a
threat to you means that they're sitting
down or they're on they're lying on the
ground that that's for most of us and
that's the only way we could manage to
kick someone in the head and in that
case that's not self-defense kicking
someone in the head is a pretty much a
universal case of that is assault and
that's what happened there so I don't I
don't buy it even if this woman the idea
that she was brandishing a mic come on
she was you could see the video she's
just sitting on the on him on a bench
listen we've all been on you know been
in the city we've seen unfortunately
mentally ill homeless people and you
know and so it would be pretty easy even
if this woman was sitting there and she
was saying something about stabbing
people she's mentally ill it would be
pretty easy to just
back away from her and you can see that
the train is coming to a halt
and it's stopping right as this assault
this is unfussy just back away from her
and you just and you'll even you go tell
the police
there is no reason at all why you need
to kick her in that and then then
repeatedly keep kicking her now you saw
that video does does it appear that that
guy was worried that this was a struggle
a life-and-death struggle then did it
seem like he was worried for his safety
or his daughter safety who I didn't see
in the video but does that that would
hurt he kicks her in the head and then
he just strolls off and taunts the
camera that does not appear to be
someone who's worried that he's about to
be stabbed that's just someone who's
whatever she said to him made him angry
and then he responded by brutally
assaulting her and that is obviously not
okay this guy's a total scumbag and
should go to prison forever as far as
I'm concerned they should never let him
out I'm all about I'm the one usually
preaching context you need context but
as I said there are certain situations
where no context is needed there is no
conceivable context where that could
have been okay to do it is if even if
she had a even if she actually was
holding a knife which I didn't see that
in the video there is no it's very easy
to get yourself out of that situation
without anyone getting hurt
she's a 78 year old homeless woman it's
just it's incredible to me that anyone
would defend that I can't even I can't
wrap my head around it from Lisa says hi
Matt and and and and also by the way
this is to say nothing of the people who
are standing around filming this who I
think should be arrested as well they
should be arrested as accomplices that
this is happening and your reaction is
to film it and and basically cheer it on
like you're watching a you know a
professional wrestling match or
something that guy should not have been
able to walk out of that train with his
teeth still in his head and his nose
still on his face you know in a
straightforward fashion I mean this is
suffered dearly for that and then the
police are called
it shows you something it's not
necessarily a statement about society
that one scumbag guy assaults an old
lady because there have always been
scumbags in the world and there always
will be but it is a statement about
society that these kinds of things seem
to happen and the reaction of the crowd
now is just to get it all on video and
they weren't they weren't getting it on
video because they wanted to get
evidence to show the police know this
assault happened weeks ago those people
got it on video because they wanted to
put it online and they thought they'd
gets a lot of Facebook shares or
whatever the police just happened to
stumble across the video online after a
few weeks so manat seemed like that
video was taken and then provided to
police as evidence no this was people
were saying to themselves oh this will
this will make some great content for
the Internet and that is a statement
about society when when that is the
first reaction that a lot of people have
rather than to intervene and beat this
guy senseless for assaulting a mentally
ill 78 year old homeless woman all right
from lisa says hi - are you talking
about teachers salaries on twitter and
saying it was absurd how how many
teachers feel underpaid given how much
vacation time they get as a former
teacher myself it tends to agree with
you on almost everything by one point
I'd like to make on this particular
issue is this the public education
system as you know is horrific aliy
broken an outstanding amount of
first-year teachers around 40% leave the
profession after the first year like I
did this is because the system just sets
teachers up for failure and blame from
all sides of the equation students
parents and administration are all quick
to blame teachers for students grades
instead of students themselves not
putting in any effort even thinking
about it now makes me want to pull my
hair out
I remember thinking while I was teaching
that I wouldn't do another year of this
for less than a hundred thousand dollars
as in I was out of there raising teacher
salaries obviously won't fix the broken
public education system and its many
problems but it might encourage teachers
to hold out longer before quitting and
feel like they're being adequately
compensated for what they're unfairly
put through lots of school districts are
desperate for teachers because they keep
leaving in droves for the same reason I
out
above I tend to agree with the position
that raising the salaries doesn't fix
the real problem and therefore shouldn't
really be a serious conversation but at
the same time it would encourage a lot
of good teachers to stay and put up with
the abuse for the kids sake I'm
wondering if that's worth it I'm curious
about your take on this yeah well this
is a problem as I said there are some
really good teachers out there and it's
harder to hold on to them especially
because if someone's a good teacher that
means that they have skills it means
that they're a means that they have
marketable skills that they might say to
themselves well I could take this
somewhere else and make a little bit
more money for my family which is
understandable so I get that argument
but to me that's just an argument for as
I said a case-by-case basis to empower
the school districts to and the state to
identify the really good teachers and
pay them more
look I'm off I I am on board with paying
some teachers $100,000 or more I mean
there are teachers that are worth that
and we should pay if you've got a really
great teacher who's just on the ball and
makes kids excited about learning is a
difficult thing to do it but if there
are teachers out there who can do that
then yeah pay the maja pay them
six-figure salaries I absolutely if we
could make them rich I would say let's
do that but that's not possible if the
idea is we have to raise all of their
salaries and if we have to keep all the
dead weight on board and theirs and as
you know Lisa if you were in the school
system there is also a lot of dead
weight so I think the answer is and how
this works logistically I don't know but
the answer is we need to be able to get
rid of the dead weight evaluate on a
case by case basis and pay teachers who
are worth more more it's there there
should be in my mind there should be a a
wide disparity in any given school there
should be a wide disparity between the
lowest paid teacher and the highest paid
because there's a why there it
in every school there's a wide disparity
between the worst teacher and the best
and I think the patient so no I don't
think I don't think an across-the-board
raise for all of them is the way to go
and it's also just the money for that
has to come some winner has to come from
somewhere and that's another problem but
if you're doing case by case raises then
I think you have more resources to work
with all right um I got some more emails
here but I think we'll leave it there
for now and revisit these tomorrow so
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening Godspeed today on the Ben
Shapiro show Attorney General William
Bar releases the top line findings of
the Moller report and it ain't good for
the Democrats or the media that's today
on the bench Shapiro show